want to know what's heating up in  theaters this weekend someone could get  hurt  ponch and Jon reunite to hit the highway  for action and misadventure in the  comedy tip based on the iconic TV show  very folksy tune in life an alien  creature that astronauts discover on  Mars may be the gem of Amarra voyage but  it could you five are the Power Rangers  it's morphin time Power Rangers gives  those classic 90s characters a modern  twist as a group of high schoolers with  superpowers must save the world see  what's hot in theaters with this week's  anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]